[Musique]
la première victime de la pandémie c'est
probablement la solidarité
arriver internationale pour l'obtention
des vaccins contre la covid-19
les pays riches se sont comportés plus
mal que dans nos pires cauchemars
d'iniquité vaccinale entre les pays
riches et les pays à faible revenu la
grande injustice bienvenue à découvertes
[Musique]
les vaccins les traitements les masques
les tests diagnostics ont été les
meilleurs armes pour freiner la pandémie
et sauver des vies mais certaines
parties du monde n'ont pas eu accès et
ils n'ont toujours pas accès
[Musique]
au début de la pandémie les dirigeants
de toutes les nations font appel à la
solidarité face au covid-19 le chacun
pour soi serait une erreur majeure mais
au moment de se partager les biens
essentiels la solidarité a fait place à
la compétition ce qu'on a autant géré
une pénurie moyenne ou d'outils qu'une
pandémie la course au vaccin en
particulier est féroce c'était vraiment
une dynamique de prédation
l'économie et la politique ont pris le
pas sur les besoins de l'humanité oui
[Musique]
la fracture est béante les pays riches
sont vaccinés 75% de leur population
dans les pays à bas revenus près de 80%
de la population n'a pas reçu sa
première dose c'est l'une des plus
profondes inégalités en santé de
l'histoire
d'où oui in Africa est-ce que nous en
Afrique ne contractons pas la covid n'en
souffrant pas n'en mourant pas comme
tout le reste du monde
comment sommes-nous arrivés là et
pourrait-on mieux faire moi je ne
comprends pas qu'on en fait pas une
priorité mondiale de se doter des bons
mécanismes pour pas répéter l'histoire
je ne comprends pas ça
[Musique]
au premier printemps de la pandémie
c'est la pénurie de matériel de
protection de masque de
respirateurs
des produits médicaux et détournement de
cargaison
dans cette compétition mondiale les pays
moins riches n'ont aucune chance la
première victime de la pandémie c'est
probablement la solidarité
l'ex-président de Médecins sans
frontières la docteur joannyou fait
partie d'un panel indépendant chargé par
l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé
l'OMS d'évaluer sa gestion de la
pandémie et celle de ces pays membres
elle en dresse adjurbilan dans certains
pays on n'avait pas même juste au tout
début accès à des choses simples comme
des outils barrières des masques mais
aussi simple aussi au niveau du
traitement que l'oxygène
à ce moment l'une des grandes priorités
étaient obtenus assez de tests de
diagnostic et nous nous sommes
immédiatement heurtés à un mur de break
le docteur Abdul Karim est
épidémiologiste et chef du comité
consultatif ministériel d'Afrique du Sud
sur la covid-19 c'est lui qui a mené la
stratégie de guerre sud-africaine contre
la maladie
il s'est avéré que le marché mondial
était tout simplement trop concurrentiel
au printemps 2020 la planète attend
désespérément un vaccin les dirigeants
de tous les pays sont sous pression pour
protéger leur population et rouvrir leur
économie
une dizaine de compagnies sont lancés
dans la recherche de vaccins personne ne
sait alors combien d'entre elles en
arriveront à un vaccin efficace
mais les scientifiques s'inquiètent déjà
il faudra produire des doses pour 7
milliards de personnes et vite un défi
industriel colossal tout porte à croire
que dans la première année il n'y aura
pas assez de vaccins pour tous
[Musique]
les États-Unis alors pressenti pour être
le plus important producteur de vaccins
tourne le dos au monde
est un spécialiste des politiques
pharmaceutiques l'Europe en panique dit
ben écoutez nous allons interdire
l'exportation de vaccins un peu comme le
fait des États-Unis tant qu'on n'aura
pas répondu à nos besoins
plusieurs experts craignent le pire une
ruée sauvage vers les vaccins on le vu
auparavant avec d'autres crises ou on
n'était pas préparé à se concerter pour
partager les choses
comme en 2009 lors de la pandémie de
h1n11 les nations riches se sont
accaparés les ressources
ils ont conclu des accords d'achat
direct
bilatéraux avec les fabricants de
vaccins et ils ont obtenu plus de doses
et plus rapidement
de l'Université Duke en Caroline du Nord
est inquiet c'est un expert en politique
publique en santé mondiale c'était donc
écrit dans le ciel nous savions qu'il y
avait un risque que les pays riches
recommencent qu'il s'accaparent les
vaccins plusieurs organismes
internationaux veulent alors à tout prix
éviter de répéter l'histoire
ces organismes mettent en place un
programme qu'il présente en avril 2020
acte a un accélérateur de l'accès aux
outils de lutte contre la covid-19 donc
on a pris des pays surtout des pays de
hauts revenus avec des compagnies
pharmaceutiques avec des philanthropes
c'est un mix de privé public l'OMS est
impliqué d'autres grandes organisations
comme de vaccins comme la cohésion pour
la préparation aux épidémies innovation
cette pi
dans une urgence une pandémie il faut
prendre des actions
extraordinaire
le docteur Tim Evans a consacré sa
carrière à l'équité et à la santé
mondiale il a été Sous-Directeur général
de l'OMS et un des co-fondateurs de GAVI
l'alliance du vaccin un des organismes
qui a initié l'accélérateur pour les
produits comme les vaccins thérapies
diagnostics il y a un efficacité
d'échelle que l'on peut atteindre au
niveau mondial suis pas en train de
faire montrer au monde que c'est
possible quand on se met tous ensemble
et qu'on unit nos forces
l'accélérateur agit sur quatre francs
les traitements les diagnostics les
systèmes de santé et le volet des
vaccins est appelé Kovacs
[Musique]
indépendants chargé de réfléchir à la
conception de Kovacs nous cotiserions
tous de manière solidaire afin que les
personnes à haut risque celles
médicalement vulnérable les personnages
et les travailleurs de la santé de
chaque pays riches comme pauvres soient
vaccinés en premier
l'objectif de Kovacs assurer un accès
équitable au vaccin à tous les pays peu
importe leur revenu et vacciner en
priorité 20% de la population la plus à
risque ou qu'elle soit initialement
quand on ne consult ça on s'était dit
que tout le monde était pour être dans
le même panier quelque part on était
pour mettre en commun puis qu'on était
pour reséparer les choses équit pour
cela covacs crée une sorte de club
d'achat pour tous les pays grâce à la
force du nombre cette plateforme d'achat
offrirait qui serait le plus large
éventail de vaccins au monde mais pour
atteindre ses objectifs covacs doit
convaincre les pays riches d'acheter
leur vaccins par cette plateforme oh oui
nous voulions que les pays riches se
rendent compte qu'il était dans
l'intérêt de tous
que les doses de vaccin soient partagées
équitablement à travers le monde
l'avantage pour les pays riches c'est
que la plateforme d'achat de Kovacs est
une façon moins risquée d'acheter des
vaccins que par les entente bilatérales
car lorsque les pays négocient
directement avec une compagnie
pharmaceutique avant l'homologation d'un
vaccin il risque gros si ce vaccin
échoue les essais cliniques l'argent est
perdu alors qu'en achetant leur dose à
covacs même si certains vaccins échouent
les pays recevraient quand même les
dosages achetés grâce au vaccin
homologué
si on regarde l'histoire la plupart des
essais de faire un vaccin qui va
vraiment avoir une efficacité importante
la plupart du temps on ne réussit pas
ensuite pour les pays à bas revenus
covacs recueillerait des dons monétaires
de fondation privée et de différents
gouvernements pour leur acheter des
doses via cette même plateforme d'achat
le pouvoir d'achat de ce pool serait
énorme il pourrait faire baisser les
prix des médicaments et subventionnerait
les doses des pays moins riches
la plateforme d'achat de Kovacs nous
semblait censée elle réduisait notre
risque individuel et en faisait un
risque collectif
le Canada travaille avec d'autres pays
dans le cadre de l'Initiative Kovacs 182
pays adhèrent à Kovacs
l'Afrique du Sud était un fervent
partisan de Kovax
nous comptions sur Kovacs pour fournir
les vaccins pour les 10 premiers pour
cent de notre population
ce qui devait couvrir nos travailleurs
de la santé
et la plupart de nos personnes âgées
mais je crois que cette volonté était
sincère
mais l'enthousiasme suscitait par Kovacs
ne dure
pastune
the promise
[Musique]
Kovacs n'était pas en mesure de
sécuriser rapidement des vaccins
[Musique]
après la pause on s'est bien rendu
compte que c'était un peu au plus fort
la poche
[Musique]
c'était une belle idée le club de
solidarité de Kovacs est né du meilleur
de nous
on ne prie pour acquis qu'on était
tellement dans le même bateau qu'on
était pour s'arranger mais la grande
vision de Kovacs ne s'est pas réalisée
comme chaque pays avait un grand
problème au niveau national ça c'est la
priorité avant la solidarité
les pays riches ont dit non nous ne
sommes pas intéressés moi seulement moi
d'abord vous vous occupez de vous et
nous de nous-mêmes
au moment où covac s'est lancé en juin
2020 deux pays avaient déjà conclu des
ententes bilatérales pour réserver des
vaccins les États-Unis avec AstraZeneca
1,2 milliards de dollars contre 300
millions de doses si le vaccin passe
avec succès les essais cliniques le
Royaume-Uni fait de même pour 90
millions de doses
même après la création de Kovacs les
pays riches ont continué de multiplier
les ententes chacun avec plusieurs
compagnies pharmaceutiques
de pays ont contourné Kovacs dans une
sorte de roche moi seulement moi d'abord
pour complètement vider les tablettes de
toutes les doses
c'est une lutte pour obtenir les
meilleures places dans la file d'attente
on s'est bien rendu compte que c'était
un peu au plus fort la poche
c'est le pays qui offre le plus cher les
meilleurs clauses c'est lui qui se
retrouve en haut de la liste pour
obtenir les livraisons le plus
rapidement possible
ation dont les prix et les clauses sont
souvent tenus confidentiels donc on se
retrouve avec un système global de prix
ou est-ce que finalement l'ensemble des
transactions se font sous la table
on parle pas de hot-dog on parle des
médicaments on parle d'un soin de santé
essentiel
particulièrement en temps de crise
sanitaire et de pandémie
envers les enfants signés par les pays
riches en jaune les pays à revenus
moyens et en rouge à faible revenu les
pays riches sont priorisés et Kovacs
peinent à sécuriser des doses
se retrouvait entraîne de faire des
négociations avec les compagnies
pharmaceutiques les possiblesment avec
un pouvoir d'achat qui est beaucoup
moins que certains autres pays et donc
finalement
pensait derrière la queue par rapport à
l'approvisionnement
on se retrouve finalement avec des
grandes compagnies qui dessinent qui
vont recevoir ces livraisons et quand et
qui peut négocier de manière
confidentielle avec chaque pays aller
avec le plus offrant pour décider qui va
avoir accès au livraison
à ce moment-là
personne personne personne personne
personne personne
surpulation au sommet de cette liste le
Canada avec 9,6 doses par habitant alors
une fois qu'on fait l'addition de tous
ces contrats il y a aucune production
qui reste pour covacs ou très peu
au moment des premières homologations 7
milliards de doses ont été vendues les
pays riches s'en sont réservés 4,2
milliards 16% de la population mondiale
c'est accaparé 60% des vaccins
revenus
qui présente bilatérales
mais ils n'ont pas les moyens de signer
des ententes sur plusieurs vaccins non
homologués comme les pays riches ils
doivent attendre que la recherche
confirme l'efficacité des vaccins avant
d'en commander mais alors la file est
très longue
on a réalisé quand nous avons fait nos
demandes d'achat
que nous devrions nous joindre à la file
que nous devrions attendre notre tour
fin décembre 2020 plusieurs vaccins sont
homologués c'est un triomphe de la
science il y avait personne qui
imaginait qu'on aura des vaccins aussi
vite le pari des pays riches paye
beaucoup des ententes bilatérales se
concrétisent
[Musique]
la plateforme d'achat de Kovacs est
oubliée des pays riches
Fortuna
lost in can country note twenty-five
en avril 2021
87% des doses sont distribués dans les
pays riches
0,2 % dans les pays affaiblibles revenus
les mois passent le nombre de vaccins
produit croit à grande vitesse plus d'un
milliard de doses par mois pourtant le
fossé se creuse
[Musique]
qui a été choisie l'essence de la
création d'une solidarité mondiale a été
détruite elle est réduite ensemble
face à l'échec de son plan initial
Kovacs mise sur un plan B un programme
pour recevoir des dons des doses
excédentaires des pays riches pour les
redistribuer au pays à bas revenu
ce n'était pas exigé beaucoup des pays
en juin 2021 lors du sommet du G7
plusieurs pays riches promettent de
donner généreusement avant la fin de
l'année
pendant les sommets des chefs d'État
disent oui on va donner 100 millions
d'os de vaccins c'est très bon pour les
journalistes et les
et le Twitter et tout ça en fin de je
dirais pas que c'était très sérieux
en fait très peu de pays ont partagé des
doses avec covacs de nombreux pays
riches ont fait des promesses à Kovacs
qui ne tiennent pas selon un rapport de
ONU sida en octobre 2021 sur les 1,8
milliards de doses promises par les pays
riches seulement 261 millions de doses
soient 14% ont été livrés
à l'automne 2021 dans les pays riches on
amorce la troisième ronde de vaccination
des adultes et la première des enfants à
l'encontre des recommandations de
l'omsider
il était profondément blessant de voir
des pays qui avaient déjà vacciné 90 à
95% de leur population
qui était toujours prioritaire pour
l'approvisionnement vaccin
de plus les réserves de vaccins
s'accumulent dans les congélateurs des
pays du G7 et de l'Union européenne
selon les pays entre le tiers à la
moitié des doses reçues ne sont pas
utilisées en fin 2021 c'est surplus
totalise 1,2 milliards de doses
nous avons une situation
où les pauvres doivent se passer de
vaccins
jusqu'à ce que le reste du monde est
obtenu leur dose
[Musique]
la grande vision solidaire de covacs
était de partager des vaccins entre tous
pays riches comme pauvres le programme
en est réduit à un mécanisme de charité
servant seulement au pays les plus
pauvres
en 2021 au total 9,25 milliards de doses
ont été livrés dans le monde Kovacs
visaient une distribution de 2 milliards
de doses il en a livré 910 millions
543 millions provenaient des surplus
dépays riches un modèle de
redistribution sur la charité et
condescendant et n'est pas durable
[Musique]
il n'y avait aucune chance qu'on est un
mécanisme juste et équitable de
distribution des vaccins
tant que les sociétés pharmaceutiques et
les organes politiques étaient en charge
des décisions critiques sur qui recevra
les vaccins
[Musique]
après la pause le monde riche a choisi
de s'emparer des doses de vaccins puis
d'empêcher les pays moins riches de
fabriquer leurs propres doses ils ont
été des accapareurs et des bloqueurs
c'est immoral
[Musique]
Abuja au Nigeria la docteur Ayo ade à la
chija dérange ce qui la met en colère
c'est qu'on n'a pas consulté les pays à
faible revenu lors de la création de
l'accélérateur acte a une initiative qui
devait leur assurer des tests des
traitements et des vaccins
le manque d'inclusion de diversité de
voix
en décembre 2021 elle est nommée envoyé
spécial de l'acte a pour l'OMS
il était crucial que nous ayons nos voix
à la table
l'une de ces grandes batailles
l'approvisionnement de vaccins en 2021
96% des doses ont été produites et
distribuées par trois groupes
pharmaceutiques dans des usines
concentrées dans une poignée de pays on
ne peut pas avoir qu'une poignée
d'entreprises dans quelques endroits
dans le monde être responsable de la
production des vaccins et de recueillir
tous les profits
depuis le début de la pandémie plusieurs
compagnies biotechnologiques des pays à
faible et moyens revenus ont demandé à
produire des vaccins et ainsi pallier
les pénuries dans leur pays oui nous
devons tous être maître et maîtresse de
notre propre destin nous devons nous
assurer que ces outils soient produits
partout dans le monde au niveau régional
là où on en a besoin
plutôt que d'attendre des doses données
par le monde riche par charité
idéalement nous aurions une initiative
urgente pour permettre la fabrication
mondiale de doses deck possible
nous devons sortir de ce modèle colonial
ce qui empêche ses compagnies de
produire des vaccins c'est d'abord un
obstacle légal les brevets sur les
vaccins donnent à leur créateur
l'exclusivité de leur commercialisation
sur 20 ans
dès octobre 2020 l'Inde et l'Afrique du
Sud demande à l'Organisation mondiale du
commerce l'OMC de levée temporairement
l'application des brevets sur les
vaccins ainsi que sur les autres
produits technologiques essentiels pour
contenir la pandémie il y a eu un appel
clair l'entente selon laquelle les
entreprises
usent de protection de propriété
intellectuelles pendant que des millions
de personnes meurent sans accès au
traitement étaient inacceptable un
excepte
à l'origine les brevets ont été créés
pour être une sorte de police
d'assurance pour les avantages et leurs
investisseurs afin de rentabiliser leurs
efforts parfois des milliards de dollars
et des années de recherche mais pour les
vaccins contre la covid-19 la situation
est différente la recherche qui a été
faite pour les vaccins de la covid-19
ont été entièrement essuyés par le
secteur public c'est-à-dire qu'on a
financé la recherche pour développer le
vaccin d'une part pour la plupart des
compagnies et même pour celles pour qui
on n'a pas fait ça a mis en place
d'autres mécanismes financiers pour
complètement dé risquer donc à ce
moment-là on a enlevé absolument aucun
incitatif au niveau de la recherche
les vaccins contre la covid-19 sont le
fruit d'une collaboration scientifique
ouverte et d'un investissement public
sans précédent entre 20 et 40 milliards
de dollars la question c'est doit-on
laisser aux investisseurs le monopole
technologique de la covid-19 afin que sa
production et sa distribution soient
gérée dans le but de continuer à
maximiser le rendement actionnarial
plutôt que de servir les priorités de la
santé publique globale la demande de
levée de brevet est appuyée par le
secrétaire général de l'OMS et les
grands organismes de santé parmi les
membres de l'OMC une centaine de pays
sont en faveur mais ils font face au
refus de dizaines de pays riches
pour pouvoir lever les accords au sein
de l'OMC et on a les autres pays riches
le pays européen qui se sont
systématiquement opposés le Canada dit
alors ne pas être posé à la levée des
brevets qu'il collabore avec l'OMC pour
trouver une solution mais n'appuie pas
publiquement la proposition
des brevets s'inquiète de créer un
précédent de décourager les
investissements dans de futurs produits
thérapeutiques
[Musique]
le Québécois Gary cobinger a travaillé
au développement de vaccins contre la
covid-19 il vient d'emménager à
galvester notre Texas
[Musique]
il a fondé plusieurs entreprises
biotechnologiques qui œuvrent dans des
pays africains l'argument pour moi de
faire 10 20 10 000 % de profit parce que
ça coûte tellement cher de faire de la
recherche et puis valable à jamais
vraiment été valable mais encore moins
maintenant en 2021 Pfizer avec son
partenaire manufacturier biotech a
rapporté des profits de 22 milliards de
dollars plus du double que l'année
précédente
en réponse aux pression pour lever les
brevets sur les vaccins moderna s'est
engagée à ne pas mettre en application
ses brevets pendant la pandémie
mais il y a un autre obstacle important
même si les recettes des vaccins ARN
sont rendus publics publiées dans les
brevets elle ne contiennent pas toute
l'information nécessaire pour reproduire
le vaccin il manque un savoir-faire
souvent non écrit que seuls détiennent
les producteurs de vaccins c'est les
détails par exemple ça peut être aussi
simple que ça quel contenant et adéquat
pour avoir produit ABCD ça peut différer
dans quel ordre dans quel contenant les
mélanges combien de temps ça brasse
c'est que tout ça c'est hyper compliqué
et pour le moment ces connaissances
demeurent bien gardées par ces
entreprises créatrices des vaccins
oui on peut dire que ici la logique du
brevet n'est pas respecté c'est à dire
qu'on garde pas le monopole légal donné
par le brevet mais on s'assure par
d'autres moyens de garder un contrôle
sur la technologie
les compagnies pharmaceutiques
soutiennent qu'il est long et complexe
se transmettre ce savoir-faire vers des
pays qui n'en n'ont pas l'expertise et
une assurance qualité peut développer
c'est raciste c'est insultant et ses
grossiers c'est ma réponse que
veulent-ils dire par l'Afrique n'en a
pas la capacité que veulent-ils dire que
c'est complexes toute cette
infantilisation de l'Afrique de nous
donner l'impression d'être en arrière
doit cesser ce n'est pas vrai que nous
ne sommes pas capables de fabriquer des
vaccins
devant ce refus de coopérer l'OMS
contourne le problème elle s'associe à
une compagnie sud-africaine africaine
byeks le plan reproduire le vaccin à
partir des quelques informations
publiques puis partagez ces
connaissances avec des manufacturiers
des pays à faible et moyens revenus donc
on va procéder par ce qu'on appelle du
River San gener c'est à dire on prend le
vaccin qui existe déjà puis on faut
essayer de trouver comment il était fait
après des mois de recherche en février
dernier afrijen parvient sans la
coopération de moderna a reproduire
quelques microlitres de son vaccin à ARN
messager le problème c'est que la
technologie est en différente au final
le vaccin et lui aussi un petit peu
différent donc la compagnie afrigène ne
peut pas maintenant que j'ai réussi à
produire le vaccin je ne peux pas le
commercialiser tout de suite je dois
moi-même faire mes propres essais
cliniques et donc on parle un autre
processus qui va prendre à peu près un
an à faire
en avril l'OMS demande encore une fois
l'aide de moderna elle présente une
résolution à ses actionnaires leur
demandant d'envisager le transfert de
son savoir-faire
la même demande est déposée à Pfizer et
Johnson & Johnson
l'enjeu financier est immense car la
technologie de la RL Messager a un
potentiel transformateur pour d'autres
grandes maladies cancer grippe et autres
il y a d'autres marchés qui s'en
viennent avec cette technologie là si on
est en train de permettre à d'autres de
produire avec cette technologie là ils
vont pouvoir nous concurrencer dans le
futur aussi dans cette future marché les
actionnaires trois films ont rejeté la
proposition là on parle de pandémie
globale et on parle d'autorité publique
qui finance qui achète et qui ont
toujours pas le contrôle sur le produit
qu'ils ont financé et
le monde riche a choisi de s'emparer des
doses de vaccins puis d'empêcher les
pays moins riches de fabriquer leurs
propres doses ils ont été des
accapareurs et des bloqueurs c'est
immoral
[Musique]
après la pause ce combat est pour tous
les pays à faible revenu et je
n'abandonnerai pas pas maintenant jamais
[Applaudissements]
au moment où on le rencontre Gavin
Niamey est furieux
la raison une affirmation faite la
veille par Bill Gates
sur la scène internationale l'intérêt
pour l'équité vaccinale s'étiole depuis
un an la vaccination dans les pays
affable revenu stagne la seule raison
pour laquelle vous vivez avec la covid
au Canada et ailleurs dans le monde
c'est parce que vous avez tellement de
vaccins que vous ne savez plus quoi en
faire et chaque fois qu'une crise
commence les gens reçoivent une nouvelle
dose
ce qui me préoccupe profondément c'est
le risque que le monde riche veuille
simplement passer à autre chose
et souvent c'est que une fois que les
pays riches en sont sortis c'est devenu
l'urgence sanitaire endémique des pays
pauvres comme pour la tuberculose comme
pour le VIH comme un peu pour la malaria
donc j'espère qu'on en arrivera pas là
mais c'est honnêtement ma grande crainte
l'iniquité vaccinale pourquoi encore
s'en soucier aujourd'hui on ne peuvent
vacciner le monde on a donc permis à des
variants de se développer si on avait
vacciné le monde on en serait pas là où
on en est aujourd'hui
après Delta beta au micro-ondes et ses
sous-varillens on en est à une huitième
vague et on vit toujours dans la crainte
d'un nouveau variant je peux pas
combattre dans un endroit puis laisser
les choses aller sans contrôle sans
frein ailleurs ça revient
aujourd'hui environ le tiers de la
planète n'a encore reçu aucune dose du
vaccin le virus est cours sans frein
depuis trois ans et plus il se réplique
plus il a d'occasion de muter d'échapper
aux protections immunitaires au vaccin
every news chaque nouveau variante nous
fait reculer alors qu'il se répand dans
le monde entier
l'année dernière des chercheurs ont
comparé l'évolution de la pandémie dans
un monde où la distribution des vaccins
est inéquitable avec celle d'une
distribution plus équitable en fonction
des besoins et des éclosions si nous
avions au distribué les vaccins de
manière plus équitable au cours de la
dernière année nous aurions eu plus de
chances de mettre fin à cette pandémie
il n'y aurait donc pas eu de deuxième
troisième et énième vague
leur modèle
qu'une distribution inéquitable prolonge
la pandémie de plusieurs années des
variants apparaissent chaque année et le
nombre de morts est plus élevé même dans
les pays riches en fait il serait
préférable pour ces pays à revenir
élevés de faire des dons de vaccins afin
de protéger leur propre population
[Musique]
des
marées
avec son équipe elle modélise les pertes
économiques liées à l'inéquité vaccinale
sur le PIB de tous les pays c'est
vraiment des chiffres qui sont tout à
fait énormes selon leur calcul les
inégalités vaccinales coûteront deux
fois plus à l'économie mondiale que la
guerre en Ukraine
les retard de la vaccination mondiale
vont coûter environ 2300 Milliards de
Dollars américains à l'économie mondiale
d'ici 2025 environ un tiers de ces coups
serait porté par les pays développés
donc pour toutes ces raisons de santé
moralité justice éthique économique
santé publique et épidémiologique nous
devons nous attaquer de toute urgence à
l'inégalité vaccinale
c'est le message que veut passer Ayoade
à la quija en organisant cette rencontre
internationale ici à Abuja au Nigeria
j'ai convoqué le premier Sommet mondial
de cette pandémie dirigée par le sud et
les dirigeants mondiaux du Nord ils sont
venus un tour de force
en plus des dirigeants elle a réuni
l'OMS et des entreprises privées c'était
un appel à l'action un appel à écouter
les voix des pays du Sud d'écouter ce
cri pour l'équité
aujourd'hui les vaccins ne manquent plus
la production dépasse la demande le défi
est autre ça va de passer ces vaccins là
d'une capitale d'un pays jusque dans un
poste de santé en région périphérique
rurale bref c'est de surmonter les
obstacles logistiques le maintien de la
chaîne de froid le manque de main
d'oeuvre
et sa collègue la docteur Joigny
ici lors de cette rencontre tout sont en
train de prendre conscience des nouveaux
défis de taille on vient tout juste
entendre du centre pour le contrôle des
maladies infectieuses de l'Afrique et
eux ils ont annoncé qu'ils veulent
mettre fin ou donation des vaccinations
ou des vaccins en Afrique à ce moment
parce qu'il y a pas assez de demandes
pour ces vaccins dans les pays
[Musique]
autre maladie meurtrière redevienne plus
pressante donc c'est vraiment des
priorités médicales en compétition et
quand on a l'impression que la maladie
on ne la voit pas vraiment puis que à
quelque part dans certains pays on m'a
peut-être plus de malaria de diarrhée
liquide de pneumonie chez le petit
enfant que de la covid-19 en tant que
maman ou papa mais tu vas dire mais
c'est là que je vais mettre que je vais
mettre mes ressources
aussi dans ces pays la covid-19 y est
moins visible car les moins rapportés
parce qu'il n'y a pas de morgue les
corps sont enfouis en silence dans le
sol parce qu'il n'y a pas de test de
diagnostic personne ne sait qu'ils sont
marre de la covid
selon l'OMS dans les deux dernières
années ce sont les pays à moyen faible
revenus peuvent vacciner qui ont été les
plus touchés par capita la surmortalité
y est largement supérieure à celle des
pays riches les pays Affa faibles
revenus quant à eux ont connu une
surmortalité plus faible en partie parce
que cette population est plus jeune et
ce virus tue surtout les personnes âgées
au-delà de 70 ans les pays à faible
revenus semblent avoir été moins touchés
cette fois-ci
mais il y aura d'autres virus
probablement d'autres pandémies
faudra-t-il alors tout recommencer nous
devons tirer les leçons de la covid-19
pour faire mieux la prochaine fois
il y a plus d'un an le directeur général
de l'OMS avait formé un panel
indépendant chargé d'examiner la gestion
de la pandémie et d'en tirer des leçons
il est composé d'une dizaine d'experts
dans la docteur Johan you et on se rend
compte aujourd'hui que dans la dynamique
planétaire des relations que on a
beaucoup de difficultés à travailler
ensemble le panel recommande entre
autres de créer un mécanisme
international pour financer une
préparation permanente en cas de
pandémie mobilisant 5 à 10 milliards de
dollars par an en partie destinée au
financement et à l'achat de vaccin
[Musique]
et qu'arrivera-t-il de l'accélérateur
ACTA et de Kovacs
ont rejeté ce plan il faudra faire les
choses différemment pour la prochaine
pandémie
malgré tout covacs à distribué 1,7
milliards de doses à des pays qui
autrement n'aurait jamais pu s'en
procurer moi je pense qu'il ne faut pas
donner un chèque en blanc à une
reconduite de ACTA pensez que c'est une
solution durable d'avoir une plateforme
de recherche et développement basée sur
un modèle de charité on voit très bien
ça ne marche pas c'est pour ça qu'il
faut repenser
ré-imaginer à quoi ressemblerait une
plateforme de recherche et développement
qui
donnerait au bout de la ligne un bien
commun pour tous accessible pour tous
et tout ça ne se fera jamais sans
volonté politique à l'échelle mondiale
et c'est important de le nommer parce
que on sait que la politique a joué un
rôle très important dans cette réponse
là
les changements doivent être profonds
des politiques jusqu'au monde
pharmaceutique pour accroître les
capacités de production je crois que ça
c'est peut-être une des opportunités
importantes de la pandémie c'est qu'on
repense les marchés global pour 7
milliards de personnes au lieu de 2
milliards
les campagnes pharmaceutiques sont des
gens très intelligents ils voient que
l'édifice est fissurés que le modèle
fonctionne pas aussi bien que tout le
monde ne voudrait puis que il y a des
solutions qui sont en train d'être
développées pour contourner le statu quo
actuel de développement de vaccins
[Musique]
bientôt l'OMS et la compagnie afidjan
seront en mesure de partager les secrets
de fabrication des vaccins généreux
messagers en juin 2022 après deux ans de
délibération l'OMC a finalement autorisé
une levée temporaire des brevets sur les
vaccins contre la covid-19
plusieurs compagnies pharmaceutiques
travaillent au déploiement d'usine en
Afrique
puis on pense que ça va revenir avec
encore plus fort
enfin toute une nouvelle génération de
chercheurs et d'entrepreneurs et guidés
par les leçons de ceux qui se sont
battus pendant cette pandémie au nom de
l'équité et de la solidarité
nous nous sommes battus et oui ça a été
un combat oui nos voix sont enfin
entendues mais un coup énorme
mais nous le faisons pour les
générations futures afin que nos enfants
n'est pas amené ses combats
ce combat est pour tous les pays est
faible revenu et je n'abandonnerai pas
pas maintenant jamais
et j'espère en tout cas que un délai de
ça quand contre s'en sortir ça sera que
on aura compris notre interdépendance
pour neuro aussi compris que pour
combattre ce genre de menace
existentielle là il faut absolument
absolument être ensemble
[Musique]
après la pause
il y a un poumon humain qui respire sur
une table et c'est juste une journée
comme une autre à l'hôpital général de
Toronto
[Musique]
la semaine prochaine a découvertes ce
matin à Toronto une vie s'est arrêtée
la victime a posé son dernier geste de
solidarité
et la donner ses organes dans l'espoir
de sauver d'autres vies
[Musique]
ces poumons en temps normal auraient été
refusé ils sont en mauvais état mais
dans quelques heures ils seront
transplantés à un patient qui les
attendent désespérément
organe ex-vivaux dimanche prochain à
découvertes voilà c'est ainsi que se
termine notre émission de la part de
toute l'équipe merci d'avoir été là
bonsoir
[Musique]